.
YOU DON'T WANT THE EMOTIONAL
STUFF.
>> I JUST WANT FUNNY.
>> I WORKED A LOT ON THIS
QUESTION.
>> SO --
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> ARE YOU ALWAYS LIKE THIS?
ARE YOU SAYING PARENTS ARE
WRONG?
>> YES.
>> WILL YOU COME BACK?
>> YES, OF COURSE I WILL.
>> OKAY.
>>> AT ANY GIVEN MOMENT WORLD
CENTRAL KITCHEN IS HARD AT WORK
FEEDING VICTIMS OF NATURAL
DISASTERS OR REFUGEES FLEEING
WAR ZONES.
200 MILLION MEALS IN THE LAST 12
YEARS.
WE SAT DOWN WITH A MAN BEHIND
THIS MISSION, CHEF JOSE ANDRES
TO HELP COMMUNITIES HIT HARD BY
HURRICANE IAN.
WE STARTED BY TALKING ABOUT HIS
STRATEGY, HOW HE DEALS WITH THE
CHAOS ON THE GROUND.
>> WE ALWAYS HAVE POSITION.
WE HAVE TO HAVE POSITION.
THE URGENCY OF NOW IS YESTERDAY.
THE MORE WE CAN DO BEFORE THE
FASTEST OUR RESPONSE IS THE
LEAST WE CAN DO WITH THE PEOPLE
WE HAVE FOOT TRACKS, WE HAVE
HELICOPTER, WE CAN USE IT TO
REACH COMMUNITIES THAT WILL BE
HARD TO GET.
WE HAVE THINGS  IN POSITION IN
CASE CERTAIN COMMUNITIES THE
ONLY WAY TO ACCESS THEM IS
THROUGH SPECIALIZED VEHICLE BUT
AT THE END IS VERY SIMPLE.
BIG PROBLEMS HAVE VERY SIMPLE
SOLUTIONS.
WE ONLY DO FOOD AND WATER AND
BOILING ALERT IN MANY PARTS OF
FLORIDA, WEST WERE PART.
WE HAVE WATER PREPOSITION LIKE
FEMA HAS DONE A GOOD JOB AS A
PREPARE WATER.
YOU HAVE TO PREPARE FOR WHAT IS
TO COME BECAUSE SOMETIMES YOU
MAY BE SURROUNDED BY WATER IN
THE PLACE YOU ARE.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE FOOD AND
WATER, YOU'RE THERE BUT YOU
CANNOT DO ANYTHING SO WE ALWAYS
THINK AHEAD AND THAT'S WHAT THE
TEAM IS DOING RIGHT NOW.
>> GIVEN THIS DISASTER NOW, YES,
IT'S IN THE CARIBBEAN BUT RIGHT
NOW IT'S IN FLORIDA, NOT HAITI
OR PAKISTAN.
IS IT EASIER TO GET FOOD TO
PEOPLE OR NOT NECESSARILY?
>> WELL, IT'S ALWAYS FOOD
SOMEWHERE AND THE PEOPLE WE HAVE
DIFFICULTY REACHING ARE THOSE
PEOPLE ON THE COASTLINES WHERE
RIGHT NOW AS WE SEE IT'S A LOT
OF FLOODING AND THOSE ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO REACH, WHAT WE CAN
REACH ARE PEOPLE IN SHELTERS BUT
SOMETIMES THESE SHELTERS ARE
SURROUNDED BY WATER.
WE HAD TO BE ACCESSING THROUGH
BOATS BECAUSE WAS THE ONLY WAY
TO GET TO THOSE PLACES.
YOU SEE PEOPLE FORGET THAT WATER
AND FOOD IS SOMETHING LIKE IT
SEEMS IS AN AFTER THOUGHT IN
EMERGENCIES.
WE'RE MAKING SURE WHAT HAPPENED
IN KATRINA IN THE SUPERDOME, WE
HAD THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS, FOUR
DAYS WITHOUT FOOD AND WATER IS
SOMETHING WILL NEVER HAPPEN
AGAIN.
THAT'S WHY BEING READY AND NEVER
PLANNING BUT ADAPTING IS WHAT
MAKES YOU WIN THE DAY.
>> RON HOWARD DID A DOCUMENTARY
ABOUT YOU AND WORLD CENTRAL
KITCHEN WHAT HAD A REALLY GOOD
TITLE, WE FEED PEOPLE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT YOU AND
YOUR OPERATION IN ACTION.
>> I DON'T WANT ONE MORE.
I'M TIRED OF [ BLEEP ].
SOMEBODY HAS TO CATCH IT.
CAN'T ALWAYS BE ME.
I'M TIRED OF BEING THE BAD GUY.
SOMETIMES OWNING A RESTAURANT
FEELS LIKE ORGANIZED CHAOS
BECAUSE WHEN YOU HAVE THE MENU
REPAIRED AND EVERYTHING IS READY
AND STATIONS ARE READY, MANY
THINGS HAPPEN.
CHAOS HAPPENS.
>> DO YOU THINK CHEFS ARE
UNIQUELY QUALIFIED TO DEAL WITH
THIS ADAPTABILITY WITH AS YOU
PUT IT, CHAOS?
>> I WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
ORGANIZATION IS NOT ONLY CHEFS.
OBVIOUSLY, REMEMBER, I SAY THAT
THE BIGGEST ORGANIZATION IN THE
WORLD.
EVERY RESTAURANT AROUND THE
WORLD IS PART OF WORLD CENTRAL
KITCHEN.
EVERY WAREHOUSE WITH FOOD IS
PART OF WORLD CENTRAL KITCHEN.
EVERY COOK, DRIVER, IS PART OF
WORLD CENTRAL KITCHEN.
WHAT HAPPENS IS THEY DON'T KNOW
IT YET.
THAT'S WHY FOR ME, ALL THE
INFRASTRUCTURE, EVERYWHERE WE GO
IN A WAY IS PART OF WORLD
CENTRAL KITCHEN.
WHAT WE DO IS OKAY, HOW CAN WE
USE THIS TO FEED PEOPLE?
HOW CAN WE USE THIS GROUP OF
VOLUNTEERS TO FEED PEOPLE?
WE ALWAYS HAVE INFA --
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE.
IDEAS AND HEART.
SHOW UP AND LOOK AROUND AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN THE SOLUTION IS IN
FRONT OF YOU.
>> YOU DON'T JUST DEAL WITH
NATURAL DISASTERS, YOU WERE IN
UKRAINE HOW SOON AFTER THE
RUSSIANS INVADED?
>> WORLD CENTRAL KITCHEN WAS IN
POLAND RIGHT AFTER THE MISSION
BEGAN.
I WAS IN MIAMI.
I WAS ABLE TO LAND THERE 24, 36
HOURS RIGHT AFTER WITHIN DAYS WE
WERE INSIDE UKRAINE.
MORE THAN 165, 167 MEALS WERE
REACHING WOMEN AND CHILDREN A
DAY.
500,000 IN THE FORM OF HUG MEALS
DONE BY 550 RESTAURANTS AND 40
WAREHOUSES ACROSS UKRAINE BUYING
LOCAL PRODUCE AND HAVING LOCAL
UKRAINIANS DELIVERING DELIVERING
TO COMMUNITIES WITHOUT
SUPERMARKETS AND INFRASTRUCTURE,
COMMUNITIES JUST SAVED BY THE
UKRAINIAN MILITARY AND PUSHING
OUT THE RUSSIAN TROOPS WITH NO
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THEY GO BACK TO NORMAL LIVES.
>> I DON'T HAVE TO TELL YOU
THIS, WARS ARE DIFFERENT THAN
HURRICANES AND IN APRIL, RUSSIAN
MISSILES HIT AND WE HAVE A
PICTURE OF IT UP HERE, THE --
YOUR KITCHEN IN KHARKIV AND
WOUNDED FOUR OF YOUR WORLD
CENTRAL KITCHEN WORKERS IN JUNE.
A MISSILE BLEW UP ONE OF YOUR
FOOD TRAINS AND EASTERN UKRAINE
AS SOMEBODY WHO SPENT A LOT OF
TIME AND I KNOW YOU HAVE ON THE
GROUND ACROSS UKRAINE, DON'T YOU
WORRY ABOUT YOUR SAFETY AND THE
SAFETY OF YOUR TEAM?
>> IT'S VERY HARD TO THINK OF
YOUR SAFETY WHEN YOU SEE ELDERLY
WOMAN, EVEN CHILDREN THAT THEY
ARE EVERY DAY WAKING UP TO DO
SOMETHING FOR OTHERS.
IN UKRAINE, OBVIOUSLY, WORLD
CENTRAL KITCHEN WENT IN ONLY
VOLUNTEERS BUT THE TEAM WAS
DOING AN AMAZING JOB IN POLAND.
REMEMBER, WE WERE IN SIX
COUNTRIES WITHIN A FEW DAYS
SURROUNDING UKRAINE, PROVIDING
FOOD 24 HOURS A DAY TO ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT WERE BECOMING
REFUGEES, ESPECIALLY WOMAN AND
CHILDREN --
>> JOSE, WHEN YOU HEAR THE
ALARMS AND AIR RAID SIRENS,
AREN'T YOU JUST ON A HUMAN LEVEL
SCARED?
>> ACTUALLY ONLY FEW WEEKS AGO,
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS I WENT
BACK NEAR KHARKIV, A MISSILE HIT
COMMUNITY CENTER WHERE MANY
PEOPLE WERE SLEEPING, TWO OF
THEM WERE WORLD CENTRAL KITCHEN
VOLUNTEERS AND THEY PERISH ON
THAT MISSILE.
THAT'S WHY EVERYBODY NEEDS TO
REMEMBER THAT WHAT RUSSIA IS
DOING REALLY THEY'RE KILLING
CHILDREN AND WOMAN.
THEY'RE KILLING HUMANITARIAN
WORKERS THAT THEY HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH WAR.
>> SO LAST SUNDAY I MEAN, THIS
IS HOW CRAZY YOUR LIFE IS NOW.
LAST SUNDAY YOU'RE IN PUERTO
RICO DELIVERING FOOD AND HOT
MEALS AND WATER TO A TOWN THAT
HAD BEEN HIT BY ANOTHER
HURRICANE BEFORE IAN, HURRICANE
FIONA AND THIS TOWN, THE BRIDGE
HAD BEEN WASHED AWAY BY THE
RAINS AND THE FLOODING.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT YOU.
>> WE'RE GOING TO TO MOVE OUT IN
CASE MORE WATER COMES DOWN THE
RIVER AND THAT'S WHAT IT TAKES,
IT TAKES A COMMUNITY.
>> YOU GO OUT IN THE FIELD.
YOU'RE NOT SITTING BACK